100 millions de pertes en 92 ces
chiffres catastrophiques pour majorette
ne s'explique pas seulement par
l'évolution des goûts des enfants 150
nouvelles réductions d'emplois ont été
annoncées mais la situation semble
désespérée
nous en aurons tous les jours et c'est
vraiment très demandé vous avez des
enfants qui viennent en caisse ils ont
cinq-six bister de majorettes les
enfants via niji regarde le présentoir
et puis demande une majorette alors s'il
ne peut pas décider l'achète la
majorette
le paradoxe est de taille mais au moment
où l'on s'interroge sur les chances de
survie de majorettes les petites
voitures miniatures bénéficie toujours
d'une solide cote d'amour dans le coeur
des enfants
en fait il semble que beaucoup de
grossistes et adopter une position
d'attenté hésitent à renouveler leurs
commandes
pendant ce temps les linéaires ce vide
amplifiant du même coup les difficultés
de majorettes qui n'a pas vraiment
souffert la concurrence du jouet
électronique
je ne pense pas que ça soit ça le
véritable problème puisque dell
d'ailleurs majorettes fait aussi des
petites voitures électronique avec des
petites puces qui durent 1000 villes
action
le problème à mon avis je j'ignore leur
leurs problèmes vraiment interne et le
problème doit tête au niveau de gestion
certainement reste la brutalité des
chiffres un recul des ventes au premier
semestre de 30% en particulier sur les
marchés étrangers recule trop brutales
ont tous les cas pour s'expliquer par la
seule désaffection des acheteurs dans la
tourmente
il semble bien que majorettes est
considérablement réduit ses
investissements commerciaux s'était sans
doute erreurs de gestion à ne pas
commettre
résultat les pertes ont atteint des
proportions abyssales et devrait
représenter cette année d'après les
commissaires aux comptes
près de 20% du chiffre d'affaires
prévisionnel de 420 devant
l'accélération de la dégradation d'une
situation que plus personne ne semble
maîtriser majorettes a donc plus guère
d'autre alternative que le dépôt de
bilan
dur dur pour les 500 salariés d'une
entreprise qui appartenait encore 1990 à
la légende des plus belles réussites
économiques